I know it's been a little bit since we
last saw you
on Survivor obviously it's been a few
days I've had a little bit of time to
digest how are you feeling now that the
dust is settled
I feel great I feel fantastic I mean I
think um having all the love and support
from basically the entire you know
Survivor Community has helped uh you
know me getting voted off it's helped me
a lot
um but I think I went out the best way
possible
um and so for that I am grateful for it
absolutely now speaking of all the love
and support I saw your Instagram post so
many comments from not just fans but
like Survivor great it's like what does
it feel like to have all that love and
support
I mean it's incredible um I mean you go
in especially with all these Survivor
grades like
you want to hit their expectations and
you want to get them to like reach out
to you and be like oh you played an
amazing game um so I mean just to have
all these people reaching out saying
that you know I mean I touch their lives
I was some inspiration I mean that's
incredible because that was a huge
reason why I wanted to go on the show to
begin with I wanted to be this positive
light for the amputee Community
um and you know having all these
Survivor grades reaching out that's
incredible I mean I got
um I got I mean I'm from New England so
I'm biased but my all-time favorite
player Boston Rob I mean he literally
like sent me an amazing message that was
great but I mean all the all the amazing
contestants that I've reached out I mean
it's just it's so cool to be a part of
that Community now um but you know you
still like have these expectations that
like you need a hit to like be be
friends with them I feel like I'm just
like I want your approval on how I play
this game that was like my biggest thing
gosh that's amazing that's so cool like
as a Survivor fan I can only imagine
like all of these people coming to you
um and Survivor fans or Survivor players
but like just people in general what is
the reaction been like for you to
represent that Community because it's
never been seen on Survivor before yeah
I mean I think it's it's been all
positive and it's been so amazing to
getting to get to read all these you
know these heartfelt and really nice
messages
um and especially from people who you
know are disabled who are amputees or
who are parents of kids who are disabled
I mean that is just hearing all of that
I mean I I try to respond to all of them
be like listen but they say oh like it
got me to believe in myself I'm like
listen if I can do this 100 so can you
and you should not ever feel like you're
incapable of doing it
um just believing in yourself is
honestly the toughest part and once you
do that
um but yeah so that has been I mean it's
been the reason why I've been so okay
with getting voted off is because I'm
getting all this love on social media
and I just I really couldn't imagine it
going in another way and so I'm just
grateful for it I'm grateful for all the
kind messages because it's really what's
been like keeping me sane and being like
okay it's it's okay that I got voted off
well I wanted to say you also like in
from my perspective kind of left on a
higher note in terms of the reward
challenge like you know you were going
through your at the at the very bottom
of that challenge and then you powered
through and you ended up winning like I
was screaming at my TV I was like oh my
gosh I was texting my best friend I was
like oh my gosh this is amazing what is
that feeling like it was very emotional
for you obviously but just that whole
Challenge and then finally winning it
yeah it was incredible I mean in the in
the moment it was it was so surreal and
like you don't think that it actually
happened I remember thinking to myself I
understand why people think that this
show is fake now because something like
this just happened but that just shows
how beautiful the game of Survivor is
because these incredible moments can
happen
um and I mean the best part like one of
the best parts about that whole uh that
whole challenge is when I'm struggling
on the beam the people that are trying
to beat me and are trying to win are
cheer hearing for me I mean that was
just incredible to hear and I think that
was a huge reason why I didn't didn't
quit and didn't give up is because I'm
like okay they're cheering for me and I
mean I remember hearing Carla's voice
and I never really worked with her in
the game and so I'm thinking to myself
Carla's cheering for me right now like
that is incredible and so like hearing
that that just kind of led a fire into
me but
I mean once once the sandbag hit the
platform I just remember thinking holy
crap and like I'm not an emotional
person I'm like the type of person that
will literally put up a wall and so I
mean getting emotional like that like
especially on National Television I have
a trainer uh one of my coaches and she's
been training with me ever since I lost
my leg and she has never seen me cry and
she's just like that was just incredible
because it's it's showing how like real
the moment is and it's you can feel it
and you can just feel how special it was
and so I mean when I found out that that
was going to be on my vote off episode I
was like I can't go out a better way
so I love looking at the positivism at
all now I do have to ask you a little
bit of game
um was there a strategy in choosing who
you took to reward or was it a bit of
like oh I really want this person to
come because they kind of well everyone
deserves it but you know what I mean
like was it more strategy more personal
I would say there was only a little bit
of strategy in it I mean me walking into
that challenge and seeing that balance
beam I was like there's no shot that I'm
winning so I don't even have to think
about who to bring and then when I had
to choose I was trying to think all
right who are people that people
understand why I brought so the reason
why I brought Sammy and Owen is because
they were the only two that hadn't
received the food reward challenge that
entire time and other than they have
only eaten everything that's been back
at Cam and so I was like if I I want to
pick Sammy and I want to pick Sammy
first this was the only strategic thing
into it especially because of that last
vote off
um Sammy was the type of person that
like can go between alliances so I
wanted to show show him that um you know
that trust and I I picked Jesse because
Jesse other than Owen was like my
clothes number one
um and he's been talking about family so
I said okay Jesse is young kids he was
the only one out of all of us who had
young kids so
I was trying to think like what's the
big like but obviously with that type of
thing everyone's going to be upset I
mean it's understandable if I didn't get
picked I would have been upset
um
I will say I do regret the one person
that I wish I brought that I did not
bring was Carla I wish I brought Carla
especially because we voted together in
that previous episode so I feel like
that I could have kept creating little
seeds to kind of work together and I
remember asking Jesse on the boat ride
to the sanctuary I'm like do you think I
should have brought Carla and he was
like I mean he's he's like no like I
think you're fine but that was eating at
me that was I was like I should have
brought her it would have been really
smart but I felt if I brought Sammy and
not all on her own not Sammy then my
strategy wouldn't have really made sense
so
yeah absolutely
um and going back to the immunity
challenge like absolutely insane I don't
even I can't even imagine what it's
actually like doing it because it was I
was sweating watching it so I was like
wow so after you know Cass wins the
immunity you guys go to tribal what was
like what was your thought process going
into tribal like were you confident in
the fact that you thought you were gonna
stay were you kind of like oh I know I'm
on The Chopping Block like what was
going through your head at tribal I was
confident that I was gonna stay but I
knew that votes were going to be
um that I was going to get voted for a
couple times from the girls
um so I was thinking you know what I'm
gonna put we're gonna put three votes on
Sammy and three votes in Carla just in
case Carl plays an art her Idol um and
then we could just re-vote
um
but Jesse does an incredible job at
going you know to me and then to Carla
and he does not tell us lies like he is
saying what both of us are saying and
they're the complete truth and that just
kind of goes to show how well he was
playing the game at that point because
we're both believing everything he's
saying
um
I think it finally like I started
getting a little inkling that I might be
going home when Jesse and Cody were in
the voting booth and they were taking a
long time they were
um and I remember that because Cody took
such a long time when he voted Mecca out
and so I was just like there's something
going on
um so I was blindsided completely
um but I I was starting to think about
it a little bit
a lot of blindsides this season not just
for viewers but literally you guys there
yeah I mean it's how it's how everybody
is playing like we're playing I mean I
think I have like made the loudest move
like out of everybody else but that
doesn't mean like that that was the best
move I mean how you have to when you go
into these games you have to
see how everybody else is playing you
have to see okay and if you want to play
some loud and energetic game and nobody
else does you're going to get voted off
um so you know the people that are
playing really quietly and are getting
moves done and are voting the people out
that they want I mean that's just it's
kudos to them so I think I just started
playing a little too loud too quickly
and I think that reward challenge coming
at that time probably wasn't the best
um but yeah I mean it just
I think uh we talked we talk about it
like a travel Council I remember with
Jeff and he was just like Jeff is always
amazed by because not a lot of us would
give him a lot of tribal because you
know you're trying to play this quiet
game he would be like I have no idea
who's going home he could never cage and
who was going home so I thought that was
really cool because I mean it's a
different way of especially the last
like however many seasons like we're
playing like a different way than
everybody else was so it was kind of it
was it was cool to be a part of but I'm
just some loud person I was always just
like I'm done playing how everyone else
wants I want to play like I want to do
this
um and lastly just quickly who do you
think like now watching everything back
who do you think is running the game
right now
at this point
um definitely Jesse and Cody
um just how they were able to
orchestrate
my Blind Side
um and it's crazy because I thought they
were my number ones like I had the best
relationship with them
um but yeah I think they're they're
definitely the ones orchestrating it but
I don't know from the preview it looks
like it looks like people are starting
to catch on so we'll see
and we will see you on the jury or not
gone yet you're still showing up and
showing out for us so the best thing my
mom had to say my mom was like just make
the jury so then like they could show
you like makeup and pretty like just do
that that's all you need to do oh I made
my mom
of course mom so I was going to be like
yes
um but so much for this chat it was
lovely talking to you and thank you so
much for sharing your story on this
season I feel like it was so important
to talk about and I'm glad it's fine was
part of the show so thank you so much
thank you